more recently researchers have begun to
explore the idea that women who are on
hormonal birth control this might be
associated with a decreased preference
for masculinity and there is some
evidence that is consistent with this
there's been research showing that women
who are on hormonal birth control prefer
a less masculinized male face relative
to what's preferred by the exact same
women when they are naturally cycling
how did you get interested in studying
birth control
um well it's been most of my career
studying women's sexual behavior and
made attraction and partner Choice
um and uh and had even done some work
looking at women's sex hormones and the
way that influences women's motivation
and choice of dress and other things to
that effect and so I've always had an
interest in women's psychology and the
different sort of biological components
that contribute to like sort of what it
means to be a contemporary female
but it was really going off of the birth
control pill that got me interested in
studying its effects on human psychology
what is the way that you would describe
to a
uh non-birth control taking person like
myself the difference in your subjective
experience of the world
um for me it felt like I woke up so
about three months after I discontinued
using hormonal birth control I started
to notice that I was just had been
feeling different recently I had more
energy than I had before I was going to
the gym again I was like noticing men
and I was interested in sex in in a way
that I hadn't been in a really long time
I started downloading new music on my
playlist for like the first time in deck
like in more than a decade and um and I
thought to myself this is like I just
felt like I woke up and I thought well
this is a crazy way to respond
um to going off the birth control pill
and so I kind of chalked it up to just
being me you know oh it just must be
something else that's going on in my
life that's making me feel this way but
then I started to really start to dig
down into the research and it turned out
that my experiences weren't all that
unique and that there's been research
that's been done now for several decades
detailing the different ways that
hormonal birth control can influence
women's psychology I'm in ways that are
very much consistent with the
experiences that I had okay so before we
get into how the pill affects Behavior
what do we need to know about hormonal
changes and how that influences Behavior
normally across a woman's ovulatory
cycle right well yeah
I ground in that can be
there's been research that's been done
now for I don't know three or four
decades that's really looked at Women's
ovarian hormones having a really
profound role on the way that women
experience the world and and even you
know the the activity and structure of
the brain so you know research and
Neuroscience for example has shown that
as uh ovarian hormones change across the
cycle that actually changes the amount
of functional connectivity in the brain
it changes
um the number of dendritic spines on our
neurons so our brain is this very
plastic organism within our body that um
you know sort of changes its structure
and function over the course of the
cycle and behaviorally what research
binds is that you know during the time
in the cycle when estradiol is high and
the dominant sex hormone there's a lot
of research indicating that
um you know women have an increased
preference for or an increased desire
for sex they they tend to engage in more
sexual behavior at this time they tend
to exhibit a heightened preference for
cues related to men's masculinity at
this time and so during the the phase in
the cycle which is what researchers
usually characterize or call the
periodulatory phase of the cycle which
happens usually between days like 9 to
14 on average if you're talking about a
28-day ovulatory cycle you know the 2018
well it's day one what happens on day
one day one you get your period and so
that's how you count forward right so
after you get your period usually about
week and a half after you get your
period women will start to feel more
energetic they'll start to having
changes in libido where they're noticing
that they're more interested in sex they
generally have more sex they're more
attuned to cues of like I said
masculinity
um in men they tend to just be more
interested in men at this point compared
to other points in the cycle we have
some research showing that women report
an increased interest in in music at
this time which is very much consistent
with the experiences I had downloading
these playlists
um but that corresponds to a fluctuating
levels of estradiol and so you know when
estradiol is high it you know it's it's
almost like the the the brain is being
directed toward everything related to
sex and the reason for this is of course
during this time in the cycle the body
is getting prepared to release an egg
and this is a time when any sex that a
woman might have can actually uh
correspond to conception and so like
evolutionary you know the evolutionary
process has sort of design the female
brain in such a way that when estradiol
is high and an egg is getting ready to
be released and women are potentially
pregnant impregnitive impregnable
that a word it is now don't worry it is
now
um that that during this time women are
just really queued into sex and in signs
of um sort of like genetic quality and
partners and um and then once uh the egg
is released and um within 24 hours of
that women are no longer fertile and
they start releasing the sex hormone
progesterone
that hormone is then associated with a
whole different set of
um sort of uh processes that the body is
doing
um in this case to help increase the
probability of implantation right and so
it tends to make women sleepier it tends
to make them hungrier
um it tends to decrease their interest
in sexual behavior they're not as
interested in men
um and in and during this time is
because the body is solving a totally
different set of problems you know it's
like you can no longer become pregnant
from sex and instead what you need to be
doing is sort of staying safe and
preserving your energy in the case of a
possible implanted embryo in which case
um you know pregnancy takes off and so
this is like a for women who are not on
the birth control pill who are cycling
the the you know a menstrual cycle or
what in the Sciences we like to call the
ovulatory cycle since that's sort of the
main event of the whole
of the whole uh act
um it's a waxing and waning between
these two hormones with estrogen being
really high in dominant during the first
half of the cycle and that's you know
generally associated with feeling
um sexy and energetic and um and being
sexier to men and then um you know this
progesterone dominant phase which is
more associated with sleepiness
hungriness and for some women moodiness
and a diminished interest in sexual
desire and so
um that is the state of a naturally
cycling woman
what would you say to women that
get uncomfortable hearing about the fact
that they are kind of at the mercy of
their hormones and they're being played
like puppets with regards to their drive
for sex their drive for food and
sleepiness and stuff like that it could
be taken as a a patriarchal struck
superstructure trying to keep women in
their place as basically bearers of
children or keepers of children right
yeah yeah I mean look uh the whole idea
that hormones affect how we feel or what
we do sounds uh sort of scary especially
given the history of you know people who
are are like sexist [ __ ] essentially
trying to keep women from you know
getting into positions of Power by
saying oh no they're too fickle because
their behavior is affected by their
hormones but the fact of the matter is
everybody's behavior is affected by
hormones
um and everybody's moods are affected by
hormones and this includes both women
and men and so you know women our
primary sex hormones estrogen and
progesterone change technically and very
predictably and with those predictable
changes so too come predictable changes
in things like libido and mood you know
for men men's primary sex hormone is
testosterone and testosterone also
affects men's behavior and mood so we
know that higher levels of testosterone
is associated with higher sexual desire
and we know that lower levels of sexual
desire are associated with decreased
motivation and lower mood and and for
men you know even though that there's a
stereotype that women are you know
unpredictable and fickle because our
cyclically changing hormones
um you can actually predict what women's
hormones are going to do which means
that you can predict how women are going
to be responding to the world around
them for men in their primary sex
hormone testosterone this is not at all
the case because men's levels of
testosterone change all the time they
change based on the time of day they
change based on a man's relationship
status so whether he's partnered or
whether he's single they change when he
has a child they change in response to
seeing beautiful women they change when
their favorite political candidate or
sports team win or loses they change in
response to even the presence of weapons
you're kidding me walking past a gun or
playing with guns is going to increase
men's testosterone yes just being
exposed to
the same room as guns
um increases men's levels of
testosterone and so you know the idea
that oh no you know women are so fickle
and and we don't know how they're going
to react because their you know hormones
change and then that changes their mood
and their behavior
um men's hormones change men's hormones
affect men's mood and behavior but men's
hormones change in a completely um you
know their primary sex hormones change
in a totally unpredictable way and um
and and so the so the idea that you know
somehow women are more hormonal than men
it's just like absolutely not true we're
all hormonal right and and the idea that
our hormones affect how we think feel
and behave is not at all threatening to
women or anybody because that's what
they're supposed to do if if we didn't
have our hormones like we'd be a
disaster because our hormones are
helping to coordinate all the activities
in our body and if like now is a good
time for sex like our body's rolling out
all the stops
um so that way we're all doing you know
all the parts of our body are doing it
together like we're gonna go and get sex
now and the brain is on the same page
and and the genitals are on the same
everything's on the same page moving in
the same direction
um and you know if stress is on the
scene you know our stress hormones then
get all of our body coordinated and
doing stress things and so the idea you
know of hormonal involvement in Behavior
I mean it is just it's just explaining
the biological mechanism or one of the
biological mechanisms behind you know
the experiences of Being Human well if
it was the case that the only sex
differences that we see are exclusively
culturally imprinted that would make
being a man of being a woman basically a
fashion choice that would mean that
there's no
accrued wisdom from The Unbroken chain
of survivors that make up the fact that
you're here right now you don't get any
of that and it also means I know that
you talk about this it would make women
specifically
kind of like puppets of culture like
just these gray bits of sludge that
usually the patriarchy can come a calm
and just shape into whatever form it is
that they want them to be like there
would be not nowhere firm for women to
stand in terms of having a nature there
is no female nature right yeah yeah no I
think that there's a tendency sometimes
for people to believe that the idea that
um sex differences are the result of you
know the patriarchy and culture
um it it sounds on the surface as sort
of this like pro-feminine idea or
pro-feminist idea and a lot of people
sort of adopt that
um but it it actually puts women in an
incredibly submissive position of you
know saying that that we're just like
passive receptacles of culture and that
the things about us that make us unique
from men aren't the result of you know
inherited wisdom that we've accrued like
as you noted from our successful female
ancestors having successfully survived
and passed on their genes from
generation to generation to generation
but that instead it's just you know it's
just uh that all of us were too dumb to
question these rules that we were being
taught and that we were just like yes we
will do the cultural thing yes we will
and and um and that's not you know that
that doesn't put women in a particularly
empowering uh position and in in the in
the exclusively culture
um explanation also like really misses
like it's like missing like one really
critical piece of
um sort of explanatory I don't know like
it's it's
where does culture come from you know
it's like culture is the is the product
of the human nervous system you know
it's like culture was created by humans
um and so that means that it is a
product of our brain and like the and so
culture looks the way that it does
because of humans behaving over really
long spans of time and um and the idea
that you know men have been so powerful
that they've like created this whole
cultural pattern that tends to be
repeated the whole world over and that
women for this whole and you know the
entirety of human history have just been
sitting in the back seat and letting men
create culture and tell us what to do
again it's also just
um you know it it it's insulting
yeah it does it treats women like
malleable idiots and men like incredibly
capable
overlords and I I don't think that
that's correct on on either side there
was a I had Carol hooven on the show
from Harvard she did that book about
testosterone and uh she went to go and
see red deer in Scotland these seasonal
breeders and when you're talking about
the effect of testosterone on males she
got to see these seasonal breeders where
for nine months of the year these
dear male deer are just chilling with
their friends they're eating they look
not that dissimilar from the females
they haven't got the antlers they
haven't got any real aggression and
they're just with their boys just
chilling out and eating and then the
women come into heat and all hell breaks
loose and they start growing antlers
they start trying to kill every one of
the friends they've just been chilling
with a couple of months before they
start trying to kill them they accrue
this Harem they try and have as much sex
as possible and then the women go back
out of heat again and it all changes and
you go hey that that is exactly what's
happening with women except for the fact
that men because you guys have got
concealed ovulation which happens so
regularly that it wouldn't do for us to
have fluctuations in testosterone
associated with that
it means that we're just permanently in
antler
have fights with your friends modes
that's it yeah yeah like some sort of
media but happy medium right where it's
like you're neither you're neither
constantly fighting with your friends
nor I'm chilling in your mom's basement
playing video games we're kind of like
somewhere somewhere in in between those
two things it's interesting what about
when the pill gets introduced then what
are the most obvious changes when it
comes to behavior
um I think that the probably some of the
most obvious ones are uh the changes in
sexual desire for example
um that's a very common uh you know
quote-unquote side effect that uh women
get from taking hormonal birth control
um and and the reason for this is
because you know the way that the
hormonal birth control pill works is um
it essentially tells the brain to not
stimulate the ovaries to produce any egg
follicles or mature any egg follicles
and
um the way that it does this is by
giving a daily dose of the same hormonal
message which is
um in with you know the what's contained
in the pill is a relatively high level
of this synthetic progesterone which is
known as a progestin and then really low
levels of synthetic estrogen and that
message getting that same daily message
you know either by the pill that you're
taking or whatever's being released by
your vaginal ring or the shot that you
get in your arm or whatever it is
um that message
when you get it every day is essentially
making the brain believe that it's in
the luteal phase of the cycle which is
the phase of the cycle right after an
egg has been released and the body is
like waiting to see whether or not an
implanted embryo is going to implant
itself and so you know during the second
half of the cycle when progesterone for
a naturally cycling woman when
progesterone is being released the brain
doesn't tell the ovary it tells ovaries
not to do anything because it's like
waiting to see what happens from that
last one before it tells it to start
stimulating uh egg follicles again and
so getting that daily message High
progesterone progestin low estrogen
shuts that process down and uh and this
does a few things right one it prevents
ovulation which is great because that
prevents pregnancy
um
unfortunately
um ovulation in addition to being
something that allows for the
possibility of pregnancy is the primary
Way by which women produce their own sex
hormones
um and in particular the process of
maturing egg follicles and getting an
egg ready to be released that's one of
the primary mechanisms by which the body
produces estrogen and so when you get
that daily message every day of high
levels of synthetic progesterone low
levels of estrogen that's something
that's not going to be particularly
beneficial in terms of promoting female
sexual desire and because estrogen is
the hormone of of conception is the
hormone of sex and uh and and so we know
that all those changes that we see in
naturally cycling women where near high
fertility when an egg is getting ready
to be released when women have high
sexual desire that the mechanism or the
driver behind that is estrogen and so
keeping estrogen levels really low is
something that is not particularly great
for women's libidos and it's definitely
one of the things that women report
experiencing at a relatively High rate
what about changes in make preferences
what they look for in men
yeah so this is really interesting and
so this is you know and I noted that
it's been about 20 to 30 years now that
researchers have been looking at the
effects of women's ovarian hormones on
their partner preferences and as noted
when women are at the point in the cycle
when estrogen is high there's been a lot
of research indicating that they they
tend to exhibit a heightened preference
for cues to in particular masculinity
that's the one that seems to be the most
replicable with women exhibiting a
preference for more masculinized male
faces more masculinized male voices the
scent of testosterone so men with the
high testosterone if you like have
women's sniffing t-shirts women prefer
the scent of men with higher levels of
testosterone
um and and so there's been a lot of
research that sort of links estradiol to
testosterone preference and so more
recently researchers have begun to
explore the idea that women who are on
hormonal birth control given that it
keeps your own estradiol levels very low
and the synthetics are also gives you
very low dose that this might be
associated with a decreased preference
for masculinity and there is some
evidence that is consistent with this
there's been research showing that women
who are on hormonal birth control prefer
a less masculinized male face relative
to what's preferred by the exact same
women when they are naturally cycling
there's been research where they've
looked at men who are in committed
relationships and they simply asked men
and their Partners did your partner
choose you when she was on or off of
hormonal birth control and then they
took the men's pictures and they sorted
the pictures into two piles right piles
of pictures of men who were chosen by
women who were using the pill and then a
pile of pictures of men who were chosen
by women who were naturally cycling and
they had them evaluated by an outside
group of evaluators who didn't know who
was what and you know was under what
circumstances and what they found was
that both in terms of objective measures
of facial masculinity which is something
that you can look at using a facial
height to width because that's something
that's associated with testosterone
levels and then just having outside
evaluators evaluate subjective
masculinity of the male faces and what
you see is that there are differences
between those two groups of men and that
the women or pardon me the men who were
chosen by women when they were on
hormonal birth control those spaces were
seen as being less masculine and also
sort of scored lower in terms of
masculinity using the objective measures
relative to the faces of men who are
chosen by naturally cycling women and so
all of this again is consistent with
this idea that the pill could
potentially impact our partner
preferences and we have some new
research and I didn't write about this
in my book just because we're getting
ready to publish this but we've been
we've been working with natural cycles
which is a cycle tracking app where they
use basal body temperature to sort of
track fertility and a lot of women use
it either as birth control to like see
when they're ovulating and then not
having sex or they use it when they're
trying to conceive seeing when they're
ovulating so they do have sex and we
send a a survey to their users asking
them about what type of birth control
they were on when they chose their
partners and then we tracked the women's
sexual behavior over the course of three
Cycles
right so this doesn't necessarily tell
us anything about like what it you know
tell us about your mate but what we were
able to do is look at whether or not
women who chose their Partners when they
were on the pill are having less sex
with those Partners now that they're
naturally cycling relative to what you
see among women who chose their Partners
while they're naturally cycling and now
they're naturally cycling right and
that's exactly what we found so we found
that over the course of the cycle that
women who chose their Partners when they
were on birth control or on hormonal
birth control they have less sex with
their Partners even now that they're off
of birth control then they're um then
then their counterparts who were on who
were not on hormonal birth control the
entire time and what's really
interesting about it is we also looked
at differences in logged libido between
those two groups of women
and there were no differences in libido
right so the women who were who chose
their partners and they were on the pill
or women who chose their partners and
they were off the pill they both had
comparable sex drive it's just that the
women who chose their Partners when they
were on the pill or having less you know
like Translating that sexual desire into
sexual behavior their Partners less
frequently uh than the women who chose
their Partners while naturally cycling
why do you think that is I think that
what the birth control pill essentially
does by flattening our you know
cyclically changing hormones and sort of
minimizing the role of estrogen in terms
of our partner choice and partner
preferences and the types of qualities
that we're attuned to when we're
choosing mates
um I think that it sort of downplays the
importance of sexiness in women's
partner choice and I think that it's
just sort of nudging that in terms of
like the you know women are making
choices about a partner
um you know you have to make a balance
like okay do I want you know somebody
who's a really good provider you might
want somebody like with really
interesting personality do I want you
know we have to sort of pick and choose
and I think that when you have your hpg
or your brain over ovarian axis shut
down and you're not experiencing all of
the things that estrogen does for
women's sexual desire I think that it
makes you downplay the importance of
sexiness in your partner choice and I
think that it's like you tend to go
after the more intangibles or pardon me
the tangibles right like okay is this
person going to be a good provider is
this person you know a stable and you
know emotionally stable and and so on
and so forth and there's some evidence
that's consistent with this like they've
been studies where they've looked at how
satisfied women are with different
aspects of their relationship based on
whether they chose their partner when
they were on or off the pedal and what
they find is women who chose their
Partners while they were on the pill
report more satisfaction with things
like their Partners Financial resource
access oh because they're going to have
assessed them with greater scrutiny
around those things but perhaps
sacrificed for stuff like attraction
masculine dominance maybe status as well
would perhaps be a little bit less
important yeah yeah and they're in there
and nobody's looked at that those last
couple of questions like the the status
questions they did look at
um you know sort of like sexual desire
and that sort of thing within the
relationships and of course you know the
women who are naturally cycling reported
being more satisfied with the sexual
aspects of their relationship and the
women who chose their Partners on the
pill were more satisfied with the
financial provisioning
um sort of cues in their relationship
and I think that what it does I think it
just sort of tilts the hand
um in terms of like what qualities are
you going after
um and you know for better and For Worse
right like there can be a that it's it's
not necessarily good it's not
necessarily bad it just is different and
um which is part of the reason I wrote
the book I think that you know
um it's just important that we know what
we're getting into
um when we when we go on the birth
control pill obviously one of the
potential scenarios that you could see
Happening Here is that a woman gets into
a relationship with a guy while she's on
birth control comes off birth control
and finds that the dreamy relationship
maybe she's coming off birth control
because they're about to be married
maybe they've got married and they're
now going to try for a child and they
haven't been together while she's been
off birth control before
and she finds out that the dream
relationship she was in might not be
quite as attuned to what she wanted or
was attracted to so I can imagine that
going off birth control can cause
a lot of turmoil within relationships
yeah possibly you know and that's a
really provocative idea and it's one
that researchers have begun to explore
and they found some sort of mixed
results on this but um one of the most
uh sort of carefully done of these
studies was one that was a longitudinal
study in married couples and they looked
at that very question like like what
happens when you have a married couple
and uh and the part in the the partners
met when the woman was on hormonal birth
control and now she goes off of it and
what they found was that when when the
women discontinued hormonal birth
control it did lead to changes in sexual
and relationship satisfaction within the
within the dyad and the women reported
um changes in both of those things but
it turns out whether it made that worse
or made it better depended on how
attractive her husband was and so what
they found is that for women who were
partnered to really attractive men when
they went off of hormonal birth control
they reported an increase in their
sexual desire and an increase in their
attraction to their partner and that's
exactly what you'd expect estrogen to do
it's like all of a sudden estrogen is
back on the scene it's like oh my gosh
like here's my libido and and sex and
this is wonderful and hooray
um but for women who are partnered with
less attractive men what they found was
the opposite and that was that they
reported a decrease in relationship
satisfaction and a decrease in sexual
satisfaction and sexual desire in their
relationship so women who have been
using the more objective tangible
metrics of success in order to judge
their partner may have discounted more
so the masculinity in the way that they
look but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they haven't got with a guy that is
very masculine and very attractive it
just means that they haven't prioritized
that they then come out of this
hormone-induced stupor and then on the
other side of that they go oh holy [ __ ]
I'm actually in a relationship with a
really attractive guy look at how
advantageous that is and now I can have
loads and loads sex obviously I'm being
like exaggerating and also the same
thing happens on the other side
I've been having a lot of conversations
about what David boss calls The Mating
crisis at the moment this sort of
imbalance between available guys that
fit the characteristics of hypergamous
women need and the ever increasing group
of high performing women I wonder
whether
The increased access and use of hormonal
birth control
influencing how objective the metrics
are that women look for in men with
regards to education employment future
prospects and stuff like that is
worsening this hypergamous nature at the
moment and also meaning that
apps like Tinder and hinge which are
very easy to put on what your job title
is what your education level is so on
and so forth I wonder whether this is
creating a hormonal profile in women
which further predisposes them to
choosing these types of objective
metrics yeah I know that's really
interesting I think that that's I think
that that's a fascinating possibility I
mean in in how could it not I mean it's
like we already see the way that um that
hormonal birth control I mean we see how
it's affecting women's achievement you
know since the pill was made like
legally available to women
um the number of uh legally available to
single women which was in the early
1970s late 1960s what you see is that
the number of women who started doing
things like applying to graduate
programs to law school to medical school
um to business school it went up by like
a thousand percent and it was just
because women now could be sure that if
they started that program they could
finish right the employers as well
presumably would be more certain as well
yeah and so it's it's just like um you
know it just like gave women the ability
to plan I mean it's it's you know used
to be for like people like my
grandmother it was like the idea of
going to graduate school would just be
stupid because she unless she was not
you know like totally changed yeah yeah
the entire time that she was doing it
she was probably gonna have to give it
up because she was pregnant at some
point and um and so for you know my
generation and younger generations and
and women who came before me who've also
had access to this like what a
tremendous thing it's done for us in
terms of allowing us to make plans and
Achieve
um but because of that you do have this
like little bit of a mating crisis and I
have another little nugget for you to
like chew on while you're thinking about
this with the pill and the mating crisis
and this was something that was actually
brought do you know do you know who uh
do you know what Dave asper is yeah the
like Health yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I did his podcast and he's like
a really smart guy and uh and we were
talking about my book we're talking
about the pill
and this was his idea and I think that
he's like totally onto something because
it's really it's really brilliant um
really interesting but you know part of
the mating crisis you know part of it is
that women are achieving so much right
so like that's part of it but the other
part of it is that men are just like
totally floundering I mean just circling
the drain and
um and so you know there is some
research indicating that men's
testosterone you know we are not Red
Deer right like our species are not Red
Deer but men's testosterone levels do
seem to be sensitive to the presence of
like fertile women right so so men
um there's been studies where they have
men
um you know having piped in uh the scent
of of ovulating women or women during
the luteal phase and you see that
testosterone levels seem to be sensitive
um to uh cues of female fertility
and so what Dave had suggested and I
thought was so interesting was we have
so many women on hormonal birth control
so much ovulation being suppressed
meaning that there are so few cues to
estrogen like sort of in the air that
could it be that men's lack of
achievement motivation is in part driven
by the fact that their testosterone is
in the toilet
um because of uh the lack of sort of
ovulating women to inspire those higher
levels of tea and as you know
testosterone levels are at a ridiculous
low percent per year it's declined by
since 1980. I mean think about that and
yes xenoestrogens and yes obesity I mean
there's a lot of microplastics and
phthalates and more time inside and blah
blah blah yeah all of that but um even
you know no matter what they control for
there's still some like factor x out
there that's contributing to these low
levels of testosterone so I'm gonna
throw out there as a possibility the
idea that maybe it is a lack of estrogen
cues I think that that makes a lot of
sense I mean Roll It Forward even more
and think about the fact that women who
are on birth control that then urinate
into the toilet which then gets into the
water supply which then increases the
amount of estrogen that's supposed to be
consumed by men no idea if there's any
truth behind that at all but if it's the
case that
taking the pill women who take the pill
are
sociosexually slash pheromonially
influencing men's testosterone in terms
of the fertility cues and also
biologically hormonally internally
influencing men's testosterone like you
know roll on top of that poor sleep and
higher levels of neuroticism people
spending time in the house all that sort
of stuff like yeah that's going to drive
testosterone down now the fascinating
thing is that women who take hormonal
birth control are priming themselves for
the kind of men that have lower
testosterone so it's both the cause it's
like the demand and the supply of the
market for this up until the point in
which they come off it
right yeah and it's like they want the
the the provisioning right like like one
a guy who's gonna be a provider but
that's also something that's driven by
testosterone you know we know that men's
testosterone levels are associated with
like mating success and all that on the
one hand but it's also associated with
achievement you know men who are CEOs
and and presidents and um you know in
high status roles
um that's that's testosterone too and so
it's like in some ways like we're also
shooting ourselves in the foot right
it's like why aren't there any good men
around who are like achieving things and
like being successful and and maybe you
know maybe there has something to do
with the what's happening with uh with
women's uh sex hormones really
fascinating idea so interesting didn't
you have you had a quote about um
without women all the power and money in
the world would be meaningless yes yeah
I I think well there's a there's a
fascinating question to be asked about
whether it is a good idea
for women to have sex with guys who
don't have dadlike qualities basically
that up until this point up until the
pill was readily available for the most
part sex was kept until marriage I'm
sure there was sex outside of marriage
there were sex workers and stuff like
that but for the most part the uh bar
that men had to get over in order to get
into a woman's pants was significantly
higher right what is asking the father
for the daughter's hand in marriage what
is that right you're going through a
final checkpoint of presumably one of
the highest scrutiny people in This
Woman's World to ensure that you have
met the criteria and the point being
that
if a lot of is asked of men in order for
them to get sex they will meet that
standard right if you need to be a
pillar of the community with a good job
who looks after his health who doesn't
have a a bad record with the local
community who all of them all the way
right all the things traditionally that
men would have been asked to do
that's the case if what you're asking of
men now because the price of having sex
for women has been reduced down so much
if what you ask of man is basically to
be in the right place at the right time
at the end of the night in a nightclub
right yeah men will meet that criteria
appropriately as well now I'm not saying
that we need to completely withdraw uh
bodily freedom from women to be able to
control their own like ovulation and
whether or not they're going to have
children but I do think that there's an
interesting
interesting question to be asked like is
it a good idea for women to sleep with
guys that they wouldn't want to be in a
relationship with or to sleep with guys
that wouldn't make good Dads because you
can as you continue to drive the market
price of having sex with a guy down
increasingly men will meet that criteria
over and over again and then you end up
with questions being asked like where
are all the good men at right yeah no I
mean you're right it's like um uh men
will rise to whatever standard is set by
women in order to get sexual access and
um and sex has been an incredibly
powerful motivator of male Behavior you
know since the dawn of time and and and
that quote about you know without women
all the power and money and status in
the world would be meaningless
um it's something Aristotle NASA said I
mean there's so much truth to that and
that is that for for men
um getting sexual access is something
that is an incredibly motivating force
in in a boy's life as he's sort of going
through puberty in the pubertal
transition and then a man's life and um
and when women don't require a lot of
men in order to consent to sex it does
men will sink to whatever low standard
is set and do sort of like what's
minimally necessary in order to get
access to the partner that they want or
the partners they want but not much more
and and so the idea is um you know that
and I write about this in my book and
it's um and it this isn't again like
sort of as you noted and I want to just
make sure to hasten to add this isn't to
say that women are somehow responsible
for men being lazy asses right this
isn't like um you know that's not our
that's not our cross to bear
um it's instead just talking about you
know when we think about the types of
cultural changes that have happened as a
result of the birth control pill this is
possibly one of them and that is that
the birth control pill by allowing us to
know that men that we have sex with
aren't going to be fathers of our
children
um it allows us to have um casual sex in
a way that we've never been able to have
throughout history
um and and not have to worry about the
long-term consequences and as you noted
this tends to shift women's preferences
in their in their choice of Partners in
ways that are very much skewed not so
much about like is this person a good
provider and a good dad but more in
terms of like is this person sexy and
might they be interesting for the
evening
um and so uh and and that person might
not have achieved anything and so um one
of the things that the pill may have
done by allowing
by allowing shiftless men access to sex
is a reinforced shiftlessness because if
you can get laid this is what I always
say in like when I'm talking to my grad
students about this sound like if you
can get laid while you're living your
mom's basement needing Cheetos like why
would you ever do anything different you
know you're playing video games in Mom's
basement and you're getting laid like I
mean I think like most guys are like
done yeah well I I had a conversation
with Richard Reeves and Scott Galloway
and Ryan Meister over the last few
months and they have blown my head off
about young male syndrome and about why
we haven't seen roving bands of young
guys pushing over granny and causing
problems and it's a combination of
getting fake signals of camaraderie and
achievement through video games and uh
Diana fleischmann's idea of uncanny
vulvas that they're getting fake cues of
sexual Fitness reinforcement from uh
porn online now if you have been one of
the guys that by Fortune of Charisma or
good looks or a good Social Circle or
whatever is managing to bypass the pawn
one and get casual sex but still with
this it's it's going to cause young men
to not need to develop a lot of the
things previously that would have been
asked of them but I gotta tell you about
it
a story of a girl friend of mine who is
a mostly lesbian bisexual and she
usually sleeps with women that's her
thing but she also sometimes sleeps with
men and I was out for dinner with her
and I was mentioning I was going to have
this conversation with you
and she said uh well it's really
interesting thinking about the way that
coming off the pill changed and she
spoke about a lot of the stuff that I'm
sure we'll get into to do with the
changes in stress and sort of the depth
and color of her emotions and things
like that uh but then she said one other
thing that I noticed when I came off the
pill was that for one week out of every
month I was straight again
that is like that's so fascinating and I
guess I I can guess which week of the
month it was
[Laughter]
have you ever come across that before
yeah so that is something that I've
heard from I can't even begin to tell
you
um how many women I've heard that from
um I've heard from a lot of uh bisexual
women
um who uh get nudged one way or the
other depending on where they are in the
cycle
um I've I've heard from women who
thought that they were bisexual and then
went on or off the birth control pill
and then had that change where they were
either completely straight or thought
that they were completely lesbian and so
was there a did you manage to find a
significant swing in one way or the
other you know it's really interesting
because for most
um the the thing I've heard the most but
I've heard I've heard it all but the
thing I've heard most frequently is um
is that they become a little more
straight when they're off the pill
so again we're looking at the highest
rates of bisexuality ever amongst women
right now but we're also probably
looking at the highest uptake of
hormonal birth control ever so how many
of the things that we're seeing at the
moment even from men's behavior is being
influenced by the pill
I know I mean it's exactly I mean
exactly yes I mean the idea you know
we've
researchers have long suspected a role
of uh sex hormones like steroid sex
hormones in terms of sexual preference
right and um and and the story that you
just told and the stories I've I've
heard from women are very much
consistent with um sort of hormonal
nudges in terms of of preferences and
for some women it might just nudge them
you know right over the borderline into
bisexuality and some women it can nudge
them right over the side from being
bisexual to
um being fully heterosexual and some
women it nudges in the other direction
and I actually had this idea because
after I'd heard this story so many times
I started thinking about late in life
lesbians and you know there's this
tendency and and you know culturally we
tend to think about this as just being
something where women you know sort of
get tired of all the [ __ ] involved
in being involved with men and that
they're just looking for you know
companionship and that in that you know
and then they start to like they form
these
um close and even sex actual
relationships with other women
but then I started thinking about
menopause and you know the menopausal
transition is this other period of like
hormonal disruption right where you go
from a naturally cycling state where you
have this waxing and weaning of hormones
including this big surge of estrogen
that surrounds the periodulatory window
that's associated with an increased
preference for masculinity and maleness
and just like that sort of thing and all
of a sudden you know over time when our
ovarian hormones begin to really rapidly
decline estrogen levels are you know
very very low in uh in post-menopausal
women and I started thinking about
latent life lesbians and um and whether
that might also like be something that's
emerging as a result of an actual
hormonal nudge where it's sort of
nudging women out of the domain of
heterosexuality and or or bisexuality
into
um into this sort of different mate
preference State well think about it
this way let's take grandmother
hypothesis right why it is that women go
through menopause at all so that they
can contribute to the rearing of
children whilst not contributing more
children that need to be reared with one
of the explanations that you have for
why lesbian women exist at all which is
kind of like a female on female pair
bonding aloe Parenting Agreement type
scenario yeah if you combine those two
together I mean what better way for
grandmother to ensure that her and some
of the other women that she needs to
look after her children and
grandchildren are bounded together
sufficiently well that while the guys
are out hunting wildebeest or whatever
it is that they do
the women get it on a little bit you
know yeah yeah I know it's such an
interesting idea it's so interesting I
find all that so fascinating so
fascinating
what about the relationship with suicide
and depression and stuff like that from
women that are on birth control yeah so
um
it's pretty clear now from uh the
majority of the evidence that's been
coming out in the last uh especially in
the last decade and that going on
hormonal birth control can be linked
with an increased risk of anxiety and
depression
um and this risk seems to be
particularly pronounced in adolescent
women so there's been research looking
at the increased risk of of you know
going on
um antidepressants as a function of of
hormonal birth control pill use
diagnosis of anxiety and depression
suicide risk as you noted and what all
this research finds is that being on the
on hormonal birth control is linked with
an increased risk in all these different
outcomes but particularly for young
women and so in these uh studies they um
categorize young women these adolescent
women as being women who are 19 and
younger and um in in for these women
sometimes I mean the risk of anxiety and
depression for example in some cases is
almost triple what it is for adult women
and um that's just due to their age
just due to their age and you know and
nobody knows exactly like what the age
Factor has to do with it except that you
know the brain is still developing
during this time and
um during brain development you know
post-pubertal brain development is
organized and coordinated by sex
hormones and so you can imagine the
brain the Adolescent brain is incredibly
sensitive to changes in sex hormones
during that time because that's what's
coordinating puberty you know pubertal
development and um and so the idea here
is
um you know that that the sensitivity to
those hormones during that period is
probably what's responsible for it but
it also raises the question of whether
or not there's long-term changes then
are you locking in a more
infantilized or juvenile or less
developed or abnormal type of protein
folding in the brain or brain structure
generally right right that might
increase a woman's risk for example of
mental health problems throughout their
life time you know you've just locked in
this propensity for depression and
anxiety yeah and there was a there was a
study that was just published I think it
was about two years ago now that showed
that uh women who were ever users of
hormonal birth control during
adolescence after they go off it are
still at an increased risk of developing
major depressive disorder that continues
throughout their lifespan and there
hasn't been very much research on the
long-term effects of hormonal birth
control pill use during adolescence but
this is something that um I mean it
seems criminal to me that they prescribe
it as frequently as they do to really
young women for things like acne for
example or period cramps or things that
aren't nearly as serious and sort of
consequential as as fertility regulation
um and there's been almost no research
on the the long-term effects on brain
development when the brain is still
developing
um and given that study showing the
increased risk and major depressive
disorder
um I I think that we need to be more
cautious and we need to see more of that
type of research being done well I know
that there's a concern around melatonin
use in
um sort of
a
pre-puberty children because melatonin
is used to help people fall asleep but
melatonin is also one of the mediators
of the onset of puberty so melatonin
levels influence that so if you're
giving your child some melatonin gummy
you can actually be affecting when they
hit puberty whether they hit puberty the
Cascade of hormones it's going to occur
due to that and yet no one's thinking
twice about putting their daughter on to
hormonal birth control I suppose there's
another
some relatively difficult risk it's
probably going to be a conversation
between daughters and mothers or
daughters and mothers with fathers sat
on the couch being silent I guess but
for the most part
there is a choice here perhaps to be
made between do you want to roll the
dice with a young impulsive child who is
going to begin to become sexually active
at some point within the next half
decade and maybe hasn't learned some of
the lessons that her mother has done
about Safety and Security and so on and
so forth
um or do you want to potentially put
them in a situation that is going to
lock in a sub-optimal type of brain
development I mean that's a that's a
brutal decision how do you how are you
supposed to get to that
knowing all of this information yeah no
I think that it's it's such it's such a
it puts people into a corner for sure
and in fact I have a um I have a teenage
daughter and this is something that I
talk about with my friends all the time
it's like what what do we do like what
are like what are the options there
aren't good options
um and and so you know that that's just
another reason that having all this
information out there is so important
because like what people decide is the
best option or the least worst option
just often you know like what it is
um is gonna differ for everybody you
know we're all going to land on a
different Square when it comes to like
making this type of a decision which is
why I think it's you know just another
reason it's so important to put all the
information out there so that way
whatever decisions are being made are
being made based on all of the
information yeah so uh Jonathan height
and Greg Luciano's work about the
cuddling of the American mind obviously
in that one of the things that they talk
about is this sort of rampant increase
in uh anxiety disorders amongst young
girls youngish girls and it's completely
in line with the introduction of
Instagram and so on and so forth and the
the intersexual competition and the way
that women do it and men do it females
and males is very very different and it
means that females can be more
manipulated more easily through these
sorts of platforms because they're more
likely to do the backbite eat stuff and
they're going to feel it more blah blah
has anyone controlled for the fact that
hormonal birth control use is going to
be continuing to ramp up at this time
what happens if you discount the base
rate that comes from hormonal birth
control use yeah no I think that that's
a really great question and I don't
think that anybody has probably thought
to do that like I don't think that any
you know it's like it's too easy to
point the finger at social media
um and it's too you know I think that
um people get so nervous about
um talking about the potential
consequences or side effects of hormonal
birth control just because of how
important it is for women especially in
this sort of dystopian
post-row era that we're living in
um you know I think that there's been a
fear that you know if we say something
bad about it that it's going to be taken
away from us or you know or or people
will become afraid of it become afraid
of it or that we can't hold on to
conflicting information like like that
we can't simultaneously hold that birth
control role is really important and
that it's played this huge role in in
terms of women's upward social mobility
and economic independence but that also
you know it can have some really shitty
side effects and brain development and
it's like I think that we're smart
enough to hold both of those
almost almost no one on the Internet is
smart enough to hold two different
conflicting ideas in the mind at one
time if you go on Twitter like this is
exactly what you see right like the the
complexity of the truth is inconvenient
for both sides and that you're totally
correct and it's one of the reasons that
I I really appreciate the audience that
I've got on Modern wisdom and also
everybody else that listens to long form
podcasts because you have to be able to
take
multiple opinions throughout a single
piece of content that's very very long
that you're going to both agree and
disagree with and the pace is so much
more naturalistic and pedestrian even at
two times speed it's nowhere near as
close as as Tick Tock or Instagram or
Twitter and it means that you
you have time to sort of marinade in the
ideas and go okay well that's what do I
actually think about that is it a
knee-jerk reaction where is this coming
from so on and so forth so I had Jamie
crams on the show last week and she
taught me about the female rivalry
hypothesis for concealed ovulation are
you familiar with this yeah yeah it's
just isn't it the idea that women have
concealed ovulation essentially to
prevent themselves from being targeted
by other women unfavorably because if
other women saw that they were fertile
that they would like essentially murder
them in their sleep so like a number of
things first off merge them in their
sleep secondly like socially trying to
mess with their ability to find mates
but also that if you know when a woman
is about to ovulate because she's
bleeding or she is like showing visible
signs of of being uh in in ovulation if
you push them sufficiently hard
apparently you can actually mess with
the release of the egg overall as well
that you can actually cause it to not
happen so this is is the you know the
why is it that women have got concealed
ovulation is a question that's been
asked for a long time and there was this
Theory put forward which is it increases
pair bonding between men and women
because if you don't know when the woman
can get pregnant you need to have a lot
of sex which increases the pair bond
because you've got this difficult baby
that you need to look after for the next
12 to 15 years before it can do things
on its own which means that the man and
woman actually bind together
she controlled for that seems like it
doesn't work quite so well female
rivalry hypothesis is super interesting
yeah how effective are men and women at
picking up on when women are ovulating
generally at the moment given the
concealed ovulation and all the rest of
this stuff right yeah you know there's a
lot of research that seems to suggest
that um that there is a preference for
ovulating women I mean I don't think
that you know what's interesting about
it is that it doesn't seem like anybody
is able to mentally articulate like wow
I bet she's fertile or you know like
[ __ ] I bet she's ovulating but there is
a lot of research that indicates that um
you know we find women more attractive
when they're at high fertility compared
to when they're at low fertility and
women generally feel sexier they walk
sexier so they've done studies where
they videotape women when they're
walking at high and low fertility and
then they just show their Silhouettes to
outside evaluators and um they walk
sexier
um and and so I think that you know I
think that there's a a lot uh
evidence that that we're able to pick up
on these cues and that we like them but
like in terms of identifying what it is
we like
um I don't know that you know I I think
that um that there's some things that
are better left uh to our unconscious
mind yeah that that's one of them
does this mean then that by being on the
pill you are potentially going to change
the way that other people both men and
women relate to you
absolutely yes and um you know
all there's so much research that points
toward women experiencing these these
subtle shifts in their behavior
um in their physiology even so we know
that women smell differently at high
fertility compared to low fertility
um you know we know the women dress
differently in high fertility compared
to low fertility and and a lot of these
things are things that um that other
people pick up on and so if you're on
hormonal birth control and you're not
having these shifts that are being
induced by that that estrogenic state
that women get enter I'm right prior to
ovulation
um I mean there's no way that that isn't
going to change
um the way that women come across to
other women and then also of course to
potential Partners
um and that's again is another thing
that's it's provocative right that's
provocative to think about the idea that
you know being on hormonal birth control
might change your desirability to
Partners yeah so women could actually be
less attractive to men because they're
on the pill because the male uh the back
of the male brain stem doesn't know this
is an elected
um reduction in fertility
the difference being this is just a
woman that is significantly less fertile
than that one over there who isn't on
birth control right yeah exactly I mean
it seems to me like if I had to if
somebody were to say we're doing a study
where we're looking at the desirability
of this woman X right and we're looking
at her desirability to Partners when she
is near high fertility in the cycle and
then we're going to have her looked at
you know this exact same woman and
they're in the same space and time
um you know because this is our magical
experiment and she's on hormonal birth
control there's no doubt in my mind that
people would gravitate toward the
naturally cycling version of that same
woman like are these differences you
know something that we would consider
like like are they you know because I I
think they'd be significant
um are they meaningful I don't know you
know it's like I don't think that um a
sort of you know a pill version of a
woman compared to a non-pill version of
a woman and it I don't think that they
would just get astronomically different
types of Partners right like like you
know wow I went off the birth control
pill I was dating fives and now I'm able
to date sevens like I don't think it
quite works that dramatically but I do
think that I do think it could
potentially have implications for um for
you know not only who women choose but
like who also finds women most
attractive and I think I think that's
also something that's worth considering
um when sort of making decisions about
the trade-offs that we make when we're
on or off the pill
why is there no male pill
oh gosh there's a lot of reasons for
this um but primarily you know the
reason is that women are the ones who
get stuck with the pregnancy
um in the case you know it's like we are
mammals and females um are the ones who
bear the cost of pregnancy and so for us
we are significantly more motivated to
put up with whatever [ __ ] comes
along with our pregnancy prevention
techniques then men are because for a
woman it's like okay I take this pill
and it has this whole long list of side
effects my alternative is pregnancy
okay I'll take the shitty pill for men
it's like okay I take this pill and it
has this huge list of side effects and
the alternative to it is my partner goes
on the pill
and so for men they just are like um
they don't they won't put up with it
they won't put up with the side effects
that women will put up with because
because the costs aren't as high
and so I think that's one of the big
contributors to the reason that a male
pill has like never really been able to
take off and another reason is you know
it's not you know it would work well in
the context of and and this is again
it's the same rationale that's driving
this
um but you know unless you're in a
really long-term committed relationship
where you really know and trust your
partner most women because they're the
ones who have the huge costs associated
with pregnancy
um most women especially in a casual
relationship would be sort of chagrined
uh to trust their partner to be yeah
sure darling of course I'm on it yeah of
course I haven't forgotten to take my
pillow today yeah exactly exactly and so
I think that there's also an element of
control there which also again boils
down to the fact that women are the ones
who are bearing the cost of pregnancy
and so it's like we're you know one more
worried about like whether or not it's
being used correctly and so we're less
likely to trust men to take it right and
two men aren't as motivated to put up
with the [ __ ] side effects that
women have to put up with to to stay on
it because men's men's alternative is
far less grave than hours
in summary moving forward what do you
think is the future of birth control
then because it seems to me at the
moment I I have no idea I had no idea
until I started having chats in
preparation for speaking to you today
with some girls that have been on the
entire Litany of different birth control
options and it seems like all of them
have side effects whether it's the coil
whether it's the once every three months
injection the little bar thing that goes
on the inside of the bicep whether it's
taking the pill
the only one that seems to be relatively
side effect free is the thermometer
under the tongue thing that you were
mentioning earlier on that you link in
with an app and blah blah blah but I
think that there's a bit of trepidation
for using that because to girls it feels
like less certain somehow uh anyway my
point being
what what what's going on we've listed
today a pretty
uncomfortable
variety of side effects both to men and
women both physiologically sexually
culturally psychologically short-term
long-term during development pulse
development
um
like what is there anything that can be
done
yeah you know I
think
something
hormonal works just as effectively and
um and works sort of within the body
um and so just to give an example but I
think we need to get more clever about
it you know I think that sometimes
there's there's a tendency for like
procedural inertia right where it's like
oh well hormonal birth control troll
work so let's let's put all let's focus
on that but it's like all right like
let's scrap that idea you know like
let's just forget about hormonal birth
control for a minute and really get
creative about what is it that's you
know produces sperm and what produces
eggs and how do eggs transport
themselves you know like what if you
know and this is like a ridiculous idea
but um so don't try to invent this but I
mean what if there was like a a little
you know shunt that you could like put
in the or like a little a little um
almost like a like a pinball machine
flap that could be like right outside
the ovary and the in the fallopian tube
or whatever that bats the egg out and
like just hasn't float around to get
reabsorbed in the body we just have no
idea you know because everybody's been
focusing on this like one thing and I
say like forget that like let's like
actually sit and think about the
mechanics of of um conception and and
see if there's a different route
um and one thing that I that I heard
about
um and this this was only about six
months ago and it was done in mice and
so this is obviously a very long way
from humans but this was a study that
was done in mice where they found that
if you block absorption of this like
derivative of vitamin A that doesn't
seem to do anything in the body except
for help to promote
spermatogenesis that if you block that
in male mice that they can't produce
sperm and from what they can tell it
doesn't seem to be used in any other
systems in the body except for that so
if that ends up being true which it
might not be because you know our body
is a mess of spaghetti because of the
evolutionary process that designed us
and so lots of things are used for lots
of different reasons and sometimes we
don't even know what they are
um so it may end up that this vitamin a
derivative is also really important for
heart valve function or something that
we just don't know yet but if it if that
is actually just kind of the thing that
it does and we're able to block
absorption of that that's great we're
done you know I mean so it might be
something that simple
um and so that's going to be going into
clinical trials as soon as they do a
little bit more animal pre-clinical work
on it to see whether or not it continues
to work but I think it's going to be
something that gets away from hormones
um and is is sort of takes us from
square one where we just ask ourselves
what are the mechanics of conception
what are the what are the mechanics of
spermatogenesis or oogenesis that we can
potentially disrupt
um to really then disrupt um the way
that we're doing birth control and in a
way that's going to have fewer side
effects for men and for women and the
problem is that at the moment we have a
solution which is pretty far from
perfect but kind of gets the job done
okay like we'll just shelve that we
don't really need to worry about that uh
and let's get on with bigger bigger
problems whatever they are right yeah I
know I think that there's this this
cultural perception that birth control
as an issue for women is solved and so
part of the you know the big uh
motivating factors for me writing the
book was just like to really make people
aware the fact that no this is not
solved and that there's you know there's
a huge psychological burden uh that
women get under when when they're going
on birth control pills and most women
who are on birth control and you know
have side effects from it and um and and
when you talk to women about their birth
control and you're like Hey how do you
feel about your birth control they're
like I love my birth control it makes my
hair fall out and I don't have sex
anymore and I get this weird bleeding
cramping thing but other than that it's
great or I love my birth control now I
am in a terrible mood all the time and I
have all this anxiety and I'm on this
antidepressant and that antidepressant
and you know this and that the other
thing my birth control is great not
pregnant though yeah not pregnant I mean
and that's like how low our standards
are because that's how little we a few
options we've been given as women and so
um you know I think that we need to put
more cultural pressure on the
development of new new types of birth
control and I think that you know I
think that there's a lot of people in
Private Industry that are doing that now
you know with the rise of you know quote
unquote femtech um we're beginning to
see that there is a greater investment
going into these companies that are um
going to hopefully be disrupting in a
positive way the landscape of uh of
contraception for women and also the
concern that you have again amongst
women that any criticism of birth
control Lodge is potentially rolling
back further developments that have been
rolled back relatively recently as well
yeah no I think that having um I think
that having uh conversations about birth
control is always uh tricky just because
of just how important it's been to
women's
um sort of Financial and economic
independence political Independence our
ability to be able to care for ourselves
and so I think that people are are
pretty touchy yeah I mean if you've been
a guy and written that book oh yeah I
shouldn't have been able to write that
book as a guy you know I mean it's just
um it's too important to women
um it's too important to women uh to
have it be seen as something that's
under threat and so like as I wrote my
book
um one reason I I also wanted to be the
person who wrote it is um I I think that
I can I was able to present things in a
very balanced way
um where I talk about you know here's
the range of potential of psychological
effects that you might experience but
this doesn't mean you should be not be
on it and it's bad because I don't think
that anything is bad and nothing is good
it's like like there's information and
for each one of us we need to sift
through that information and then make
decisions about ourselves because it's
like I know what works for me but that
doesn't mean that I know what works for
you and so it's just really about
providing all the information in a
really even-handed way
um where I I think yeah and sort of
having that conversation in the context
of just how important
um this has been for for women in terms
of
um putting us in the position that we're
in now
um economically and and socially all
right sir let's bring this one home why
should people go if they want to check
out the stuff that you do online
um they can find me online at
sarahehill.com and that's Sarah with an
H and you can also find me on all
different
um social uh different social media
platforms and my handle is at Sarah e
hill PhD Sarah I appreciate you thank
you thanks what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]